happened at the time.
conference I'm like you learned. I'm less free.
I'm so excited that you like.
Hi, can you hear me?
Yeah, gotcha.
Okay, I'm going to staff camera.
my tooth fell out on the way home from the airport.
So, um...
I cannot get it replaced until Thursday.
So I'm gonna be off camera.
- Wow.
That sucks.
I'm sorry to hear that.
- Yeah.
- Did you get in a fight?
No, I haven't been your name.
bit into something and it came off and I was just like
And I think I swallowed it too, because I...
I just think.
Sorry.
That sucks pretty much.
But that's also pretty funny.
You're a comedian. You think it's fun.
I'm just like, I'm like, okay.
And then Jeff is in town and you're just like, hey,
what's me to like, no, I said I have.
a little dignity left.
I'll catch you next time, buddy.
So, Marcy's gonna be like five minutes.
minutes late. Sure.
And so...
I think
for today.
The goal of our meeting should be to
to like walk through what we had scoped.
out for the engagement and.
show you guys what I've put together and what I've put in place.
from both a user.
standpoint but then also administratively what it looks like on your end.
And just making sure that
you have a good foundation of.
whether you have the functionality and
place that is like at that beginning stage.
where people can come in and easily.
sign up. Perfect.
Thanks for watching.
But I'll wait for my...
she said please re send the link.
Okay.
Yep, just saw that.
Let's keep it safe.
[MUSIC]
Okay, I should have just gone.
Spinning this picture.
of me this avatar I don't know where it's coming from but
that that's from like 10 years ago.
Is it just because you're logged in?
Yeah.
I'm like logged in using a relatively old.
email address and I took this
picture in Burlington, Vermont with Nikki when we went there.
like right before our wedding 10 years ago.
Um, you can't really see but I
I look less ruined in that.
picture. [laughs]
Have you by any chance like swung by the jubling?
website. No, not yet. I was gonna wait. I didn't know.
you know, when it would be ready.
So.
Sure, yeah.
Hi, Marcy. Hello.
How you doing?
I'm great.
I'm so confused. I was looking at my
regular inbox and this is in Google.
And like, I never go to Google unless I go to Jubilee.
and whatever. Anyway, I'm sorry.
It's technology is like a good thing.
but too much of it is not.
I use Macintosh. So.
Google, Teams, all these things that don't speak to me.
Got it. Yeah technology
Okay, hi Jess.
Hi.
So, Marcia, I was thinking...
Today we could walk through...
what functionality I've built into the website.
site and basically getting
to the point where people who are interested
can very easily sign up to join the organization.
and then also the security.
that comes with that, that protects your members from...
outside people being able to see
the events you're doing and just the
other changes that I've made to make it all a lot more usable.
for both you and Jess. Great.
Alrighty, the thing that I
- Okay. - I'm sorry.
- Timmy, are you recording?
recording for notes. I can yeah I'll set that up.
now. Um,
Okay, so...
The other thing that I wanted to just highlight is
right now there's just placeholder imagery in here
So if you see anything that doesn't work for you, please call it out.
But it's sort of just just
place so that we can have something to work with.
Okay.
Alrighty.
Um...
So this is the homepage for Jubilee.
And it's a very simple and straightforward.
page. Right up at the top it says exactly what it is.
is and gives you the joy to
jublin call to action all you have to do
is put in a name in your email address, indicate
Which of these you're the most interested in?
And then what that will do...
is it wills? Hit that because it's showing
you're showing the email addresses but what's your
drop down for most interested.
Okay.
Yeah, so I'll just walk you through what it's gonna look like.
All right, so I'll do the Dux and then zit.
Chingo lines. And.
and the drop-downs for "I'm most interested in" can be updated.
however you would like, but right now it says it events book club.
learning circles and professional development.
Okay, it's one choice, one option.
currently, but we can make it so that it's a
a radial where you can choose multiple.
So, for right now, I'll just click event.
and what the user would say.
on their side. It's just a thank you to indicate that.
that we have received their request to join.
And at this stage...
(upbeat music)
(phone ringing)
- Hold on a second, here's the shirt.
It's an alert one second.
Sure.
Okay, if the siren goes, I gotta go.
So I'm here for...
Hopefully, it does it.
I'm here.
Yeah.
Okay.
Um, from here.
The way that it's set up right now, Marcy, is that you and Jess...
would both receive a notification that somebody has attempted.
to join jubling. Okay, it goes.
or email or goes to inflowat.
It goes to both of you.
It can just go to info@jubling.org.
if you'd prefer, but right now it goes to the two of you.
Okay, just our personal emails.
like the Rubenwich Jessica.
Okay. Okay, we have to just.
Jess also we have to follow up with that because on wicks
or through GoDaddy.
We just recently added to
email capabilities member.
which we didn't set up. So to me we have
I think Jessica had...
jubling.org and Marcia jubling.org.
We just bought them like
We didn't do anything with them because we didn't know how to...
Set it up.
Sure, okay, I can make sure that.
the emails get routed.
discuss that later on. But yes, that is something that we could set up.
Okay, so
would get a request to your emails that.
that would be indicating the name of the person.
and basically just what they filled in.
here and that is the authorization game.
that either one of you would be able to say.
This person can come in, this person can.
And so because their email address
is being given to you if there is any additional vetting.
that you would like to do, you would then have their emails.
so that you could follow up with them and just.
get more comfortable with making sure.
whether or not you want them to join.
But if it's somebody we know they're legit, we just click.
Okay, or whatever it is.
Yes.
Yeah, there is a... currently I have a process...
up where you just have to change.
on the administrative side that you've accepted them,
and then...
they would have access into the community.
[MUSIC]
(upbeat music)
>> I don't know if that's --
That's the--
Sure.
Sorry, Ryn.
Well, what we can do is...
continue because it's being recorded right now.
I just, I would say.
say like, you know, let's pick it back up, but I know that.
There's a board meeting later today.
I hope everything's good with okay. I didn't know if you were right
into a shelter, what was going on?
If I have to do that, I'll let you know somebody there was a
siren nearby, but it wasn't here.
We're still, we're still, we're still.
What happens is just to let you know, in case I scoot.
We get a warning, a warning depending on where the
missiles coming from. If it's from Iran, it gives us
15 to 20 minutes before the siren.
goes off if it's in our neighborhood.
If it's from the library.
on or somewhere else that's close
So we got like three seconds and then the sirens go off.
So if the siring goes, I gotta go in the mama.
safe room and if not I just sit here and I
wait and try to pay attention because I'm
distracted by is it going to go off or not?
So that's what's gonna happen.
So I will...
You're saying that I don't have your full
attention, Marcy. You have my full attention.
You just have a little heart at school.
is what I'm telling you.
Yes, we are recording this absolutely.
- Absolutely do whatever you want to do.
- Oh, there it is.
Okay, bye
Be careful and be safe.
It's wild right?
wild. Oh my god.
God!
- Well, all right.
Let's continue.
Okay, Jess.
Let's say that I was admitted.
into the community on your end.
So what the...
I'll just finish with the user sees and then we'll pivot over
into what you see administratively.
I'm in the community now and so now I can go
Click Access Community.
it would bring up here the free community.
access into jubling it doesn't have the insider option.
anymore it's just the one place but this is set up this
way in order to have that gating that we
need to protect your people.
Okay.
and you click the product, we can also change it
so it doesn't save you.
product you can say like enter community you can say whatever
we needed to just so that people are like, what product are you
talking about. Right. Yeah, that's
I just wrote that down. That's a good call because I was just like
Some of the verbiage here makes it very...
I like that these are like...
Triplets. Jewish.
business triplets.
Yeah, um, there's a
There's not a lot of stock photography.
but women who observe.
Sneela or however you pronounce that.
So great. I just think it's funny cuz it's like looks like this
same woman three times.
- I need to make them.
look less similar and...
look more like real human beings instead of
people who are complying with this.
Sneva but are still robots. So I got it.
I didn't change that.
But it'll do fright.
right now. Okay, so the
The user would then get into this kind of main home.
page here and it's kind of structured like
any other social media feed that you would see on Facebook.
book that you would see on LinkedIn. It's meant to be
very familiar and this is kind of how it was set up.
previously, but the difference now is that
there is a lot less clutter on the side.
I hear there are multiple sections, things that are--
redundant and this feed here this can
be customized that we're gonna be one we don't have to have the answer.
What kind of meetups could we call it events?
Like are you able to change that?
I think I'd have to see because...
because this is like part of the community module.
there are certain things that are just...
Like that's a good jobby term and I'm not sure.
to where that I can change what the button says.
But what we can do is we can do it.
do is make it very if we can't we can make it very clear.
that like we can have
like a pinned post right up here at the top that is just
perpetually here. That is just like a quick like.
rundown of terminology like
this is where you should go for this, this is where you should go for this.
Or what we had previously was...
is like a pre-recorded video of Marcy.
of her talking through it as like a welcome.
We can set that.
up as well. I think instruction wise it would be good.
for it to just remain text so that we can keep it updated.
I think some people just want to get through it so sometimes
they're not watching videos. Yeah. Yeah. We
You can set it up so that it's a very quick like bing bing like you.
you see exactly where you need to be.
Thank you, Nick.
She brought me a spoon.
Oh, what a waste. I know.
I know, right? I'm so lucky.
Okay, so, but yeah, this
right now is a splash page and then on the right is just the
breakdown of the events that are coming up.
so you can just quickly click over to them.
What I need to look in.
is to see if we can judge this up a little bit more with...
potential thumbnails of the graphics so that we can
have hopefully not shiks a purple lady.
Lady is in the.
Right. I'm now. But.
You know, just to make it more clear.
on the feed that this is where...
where you would go to like click into events.
Okay. Um.
It's interesting too because it has like these recordings.
things there, but I wonder, like, it takes
away from the meetups like the recording like
I feel like it's like if you go into meetups.
and you want to see the list, those recordings are kind of...
clog it. Can we? Yeah. Find somewhere else.
But then, or is that--
Totally.
You could just drop--
this down to a different part of the page it doesn't have to.
at the time.
We can also change what the default looks like.
looks like so if we wanted to do this by a calendar instead.
And probably wouldn't just because, you know, unless you have
a lot of really a lot of stuff in here.
Week might be a little bit better.
Probably not day. So yeah, list is probably the best way to go especially
with the graphics that we have here.
But yes, recordings can be dropped down. It can be put into a...
a different part of the site so that it's not as
prominent just because most people are going to be trying to go to
new events and not look at old recordings.
So yeah, so right now.
This is the very simple path for people.
people to just access the
events that are happening and that you're
putting into the
Putting into the pipeline.
There is any number of people.
of other customizations that we can make to this where we have separate pieces.
like we have to do like.
I would like to just take out that clutter too.
where it says community access and just have when you come in.
There's just, even what...
That's the leader board.
I don't even think we need that.
Yeah, it's a way turn.
I would only make this visible again.
And if you honestly had a lot of engagement.
because it's a way to gamify like engage.
engagement from people.
- I think we just need like...
Meetups or say events, right? You can click on
and then maybe news.
where we can keep like our, like is there somewhere where
can store.
maybe newsletter or.
And then, could you do a separate one
where it just says like...
Event recordings or something.
I could see if we could call
carve out the recording section and have it be.
It's own separate thing or maybe like subsidiary to me.
up here.
Because you can like defeat. I don't know if we really need to
Because the feed is just...
I don't think anybody's really gonna need this.
Sure. Yeah, if ultimate...
people are not going to be coming in here too.
have interactions with one another.
in the way that you would like on a Facebook or
on. Hey hang on one second. Hang on one second. Yeah.
- Yep, yep, yep.
[ Inaudible ]
Thank you.
Sorry about that.
No, it's all good.
Okay, go ahead.
Yeah, if-
If people are not likely to use this as a way of...
way to interact with each other like it on a
message board or in some other way that's familiar.
social media, then the fee doesn't have to be the main
page it can be whatever you want it to be.
Yeah, I think, but no.
I get it. Yeah, I just think it make it easy. Just have like.
events or whatever meetups.
news and then we could put feed next.
but like if they want to talk to each other but.
or an impast event.
to recordings or archives, I guess.
we could call it if they allow you.
Yes, I have to look in the seat.
exactly how much.
Customization can be done for
certain things like this but there's quite a bit of customization.
that you can do. Excuse me, I'm an individual.
pages so yeah I can look into this.
that. So let's see here.
This overall is...
accomplishing the goal of making it very...
very simple and straightforward and free and very obvious.
free to people to get into.
this portal here. I'm gonna back it.
out and just go back to the home page.
And do you think it's obvious too that if they wanted to--
register. So say we were like, if you want to come to this
event.
register when they go to the event register.
go into Kajabi and they click on the
one of the events to say that you
Go in.
And then you're like, "Ooh, I really..."
That looks good or whatever it looks like.
maybe club, okay?
Oh, sign up, okay.
Yeah.
And because you already have access, it's just a matter of...
saying like, yeah, you're nay. Am I going, am I not going?
And then you can...
added to your calendar from here. You can share it with people from here.
and you can see who else has signed up.
Okay.
And
So, it's also my understanding.
that you had like a z...
Zoom, like a separate Zoom.
you would connect to it. Is that true?
That'll be kidding.
I mean if it's just as easy to continue to do it in case.
can job be as long as they have that,
they get that length and that's.
I don't think we need a separate zoom.
- Exactly, yes.
So I think yeah, having Zoom is like a hat on a hat like
you can just do it right within the area.
integration that's in Kajabi just to keep it simpler.
Okay. So...
So yeah, that's what it would look like for people to sign up.
very straightforward and.
Is there anything else like
from the user experience side and within the community
you'd like to look at because I can pivot back to the homepage.
No, I guess the only thing would be...
Um
maybe like on the homepage too.
we had like a whole
section there just might be so one I
I think that they're, why can't I find you?
Where are you?
I think that there is.
There you are. Okay. I think there.
maybe like an about us, right?
at the top.
because it does say community access all the
at the top, donate, and then maybe just
and about us and then we can.
Sure.
Put that.
You know, Amy, just--
just--
where there is everything and then.
And then, um...
The only thing would be too, like maybe like...
when it's about us, like I don't know if there's a drop.
but it would be like, maybe say what.
being what you get being a member.
So, you know,
Okay.
My, you know, our whole thing and
and I can like give you all of these,
but it would say like.
You can be part of a habura, you know.
ongoing events.
And so let's see what I'm doing.
I currently have on the homepage 'cause the less.
um the less like stratification.
the better. And so if like we cover
most of this stuff on the homepage or if
if like let's say about us like automatic,
it just like.
swoops you down to a part of the homepage that
has what you need about it. The the last it can be.
like a rabbit warren of like a bunch of different nested pages.
with one another. I'm more just like it's all in one place.
place, but people can still click things because they're like, I
I want to learn about that, but then it's already on the page.
Yeah, so well, I think we can experiment.
setting it up both ways and then you can see
you and Marcie like. Yeah, so currently.
I just have like very general stuff right here now
a lot of imagery, but it does give you
the basic rundown of what events are possible and
It has the call to action for check for the latest events.
at which point it would hit you with...
again. So access to bling events.
What we can do is have a
this gate page. Have more detail about it.
about what the events would include.
But then by the end of it
And it's coming in a little weird, so I need to--
I need to troubleshoot it.
It's supposed to say down here and it did say and it's not.
showing it for some reason is login.
or join.
At which point?
you would just fill in your name, email, and what you're interested in.
and you would submit. For some reason it's not showing the text.
on the box. I don't really know why. I'll have to fix that.
When we say most interesting.
most interested in.
Ms. Riesen, we're asking that.
don't have to it really just
makes it so that if you wanted to
more closely tuned and follow up or marketing today.
them. You can. You don't have to, though.
and because it's just one more thing that people have.
to fill in.
Alright, okay.
But yeah.
So...
So it doesn't have to be there, but that functionality is there if you wanted to take
advantage of it down the line if you wanted to like
get more granular with how you would market to people.
So we can get out this page with more.
detail about the events.
But it also makes it very clear that like if you
want these events you need to either log in or you need to.
request access. That's what these buttons were supposed to say.
Alrighty, so I'll back out.
As you scroll down on the home page.
page it has. I have just like a short section.
about what your values are.
which can connect to the about us.
And then there's a final call to action here about becoming a
a member once you get to the end of it. We can make this
homepage more substantial, but by including more.
information on it. We can also have
have it so that the heading...
here follows you throughout the page so that
like access community and doing it would float down.
And so if you wanted to jump to a specific page,
you could just--
just click that, it's like a running table of contents.
But right now, right now.
right now this just accomplishes the goal.
of making it so that people can easily join Jubilee.
thing. The other thing that's user
side is this donate page. So I'll
show you that now.
So this donate page it
initially, like on the wicks page, it was
would just like send you immediately to Zephi to do.
donate. And I feel like there was
I haven't edited this after you and I texted,
so I need to do that.
but I feel like there was an opportunity here.
to kind of grease the wheels a little bit.
Right.
And so like this is the
explanation of like why they should.
Support jubling.
Perfect. Okay.
It can look different, it can be written differently.
But just the point is that we're not doing it differently.
just trying to like kick them over to Zafi.
When...
without any context, whereupon it that
routes them to your Zephyr donate page.
and you fill it in right here and you continue.
Amazing.
So I'll back out.
So, yeah.
The thing that I've learned is like the more calls to action.
you have. Maybe not necessarily this.
densely packed here, but the more calls to action the
easier it is, like if somebody just kind of scrolls down,
it's like there's only--
always going to be a button for the clay.
Yeah, like if you're making a decision.
And then also you're like, well, okay, I'm ready to do it.
the buttons there. Yes.
And then also there's a call to action to join.
the community. So that makes it easier.
to to wrap them that way.
as well.
- I like it.
- So, plenty more pages that can be created.
But as far as the scope of trying to
make it easier for people to sign up, make it easier for people to sign up.
for people to just see what is available.
once they are signed in protecting.
the sign up process and then also making it so that people can donate.
Like from the user side, that's what I've put into.
place so far. I love it, Timmy.
It's great. I think, you know, when Marcy sees it.
It should probably want to just tweak the content, right?
like just make it a little bit more robust.
but yeah, like it totally show like.
I like simple, right? I don't like overwhelming stuff.
It's like this is what it is because I feel like a lot of the
The selling about it will be word amount.
by us reaching out to people saying join.
So...
like by the time they come to this.
Page they already have an understanding of what it is
but it's a simple way to join.
And the
them the important part is once they join they get
some kind of welcome letter, right, that may be iterated.
what they have access to now.
And you know, like maybe that's just the welcome letter that already
that automatically goes out and then.
Once during the job, you just scream.
that because really that is a community but
Let's be honest, we don't even get any more now.
So.
They can go there at any point to see.
what events are coming up or just to make sure that they are signed up.
They can go back to...
to get recordings like if they're part of book club and--
and they want to see what happened.
And then you have a feed if we want,
but I really doubt people are gonna--
talking back and forth to each other in there.
Like I just say.
but simple where here's the hub where.
everything's kept and here's where all the events are that you can
sign up for, but mainly it's just that we have
a direct line when we're inviting people.
that they can register.
And then
somewhere where we can record it and
then keep it. Like that's really all we need.
Fergie.
and we need to do a job. And I mean it ends and that's it.
So it would be nice.
And then the other part of it--
and sorry if I'm--
jumping ahead.
No, no, no, don't just.
It is like.
then would just be like, okay, great. Now that we have
customer list in there we have everybody in there.
And I want to send out marketing or I want to send out emails.
or I want to automate newsletters because.
A lot of this too is like I can get all these.
information and we can set it up to automate and.
and send out like once a month or whatever the cate is.
is these things are reminders.
And that's really kind of like what I want to use the good job before.
too so I'm not manually having to do it or put it.
- Then.
- Right.
Yes.
So that is a good, sorry.
eating Billy cereal that she didn't want to eat this morning.
I'm sure you're familiar with that process.
just eat your children's uneaten food.
- Oh yeah.
- That's mostly what I eat.
So, I'll, a couple more years.
user side things that I can show you by way of.
I have like the welcome email that you were talking about just to show you what that
would look like on the user side.
And I had his book for an hour.
So if you're cool, we can go to the administers.
straight upside. Yeah, absolutely. Can you give me one second?
and I just want to take a bio break and we'll be right back.
Sure.
Okay.
Okay, sorry about that. I'm ready.
All righty, I'll be back on camera.
around just a moment.
So what you're seeing here.
let me pull up an actual email. So when you sign up for
jubling, this is the first email that you'll get.
Obviously this is just a sample, but.
We don't have to have the triplets here.
Just place older.
But yeah, so it just kind of gives me that.
you a quick automated view signed up.
This is your welcome thing. This is what it tells you.
We can customize the copy on this no problem.
I think that the...
This is an older email.
I did wire.
it so that the upcoming events button here.
takes you to that events page.
Okay.
But what I also have...
is where is it?
I set up some...
automated follow-up emails.
And I think the best way to
show that rather than from my email is to
show you on the administrative side.
Alright, so let me just do...
Thank you.
Oh, just like that.
back in.
Right now.
Sorry, just give me a sec.
There.
- There it is.
Alrighty.
So...
So as far as like new
whose letters and automation of marketing, like there is a lot.
that you can do in Kajabi.
just kind of going through the different functionalities.
here and seeing what is capable.
what it's capable of and how you can automate.
and how you can use it. There's a lot to be done here.
So it's great. You have access to a lot of things.
you can do. As far as that.
Initial cadence goes
It's kind of bringing it back to what we were talking about at TPMG.
I'm going to go to marketing and an email campaigns.
This is just one example that you can kind of like.
iterate on and be able to like ex.
extrapolate like how this automation, how this
Cadence works.
So just like--
cadence that you would try to automate through PyDrive.
I have this jubling welcome sequence that comes up.
So I'll click into this.
Amazing, because they always...
I never knew how to work this.
So I love--
you figured it out. Yeah.
And so you can see that it gives you all of the...
analytics about what's gone out.
So when you sign up, immediately you get the one.
welcome the email. And then day two after at a
11 a.m. Central, you get another one and
and then day five you get another one.
And you can.
and Daisy Chan this however far you want.
Um, maybe...
and on them with a million emails is probably not the
best idea but definitely hit them quick hit them
that really remind them that they signed up.
Yeah, so the
Yeah, this is the...
where you can edit the content, you can...
have a template so that it's very easy to just copy.
it over and bring like the the footer and
You can bring the header in, you can bring the triplets in.
if you want and then you can update.
the copy however you would want.
It's pretty straightforward.
forward. But ultimately, this
This is where the sequencing comes in.
So when do you send it?
What does it look like as far as administrative?
how do we know what it is, but then this is what it says to the
user on their side in the subject line.
This is what shows up when you're just looking at it in your end.
and it doesn't have, like you haven't opened the email.
this is what it would say.
little peek of what it's about, right?
- Yeah.
Yeah, and so this is just
connected to
It's just all part of that chain there.
And so I'm gonna cancel out with this because we're not gonna add another...
email, but I do have this jubling welcome template.
set up here, you can make changes to the template so it's easy.
easy for you to kind of repeatedly get what you want.
Structure.
and text wise. But yeah.
So that's just one example of a campaign you can set up.
All right.
So we have.
Welcome campaign for emails and then.
Um...
Okay, great.
But basically whatever other things that you...
you would want to set up, like, it's all based on trigger.
So when somebody...
signs up for a meetup or something like that.
You can have...
a campaign got to them after
word to kind of like follow up with them and say like hey like what did you think
of the meeting or like here's the next event.
that are coming through.
Basically, just whatever you can do to keep.
Continue to keep jubling in people's heads.
Um, based on their behavior and based on how they
interacting with the website, you can set that
up in here and um
It's fairly straightforward how to get it.
in there. It's just a matter of just like clicking buttons and experiment.
with it and obviously.
if Jubilee wants to continue to work with me, like I can
helps set that up for you guys. So.
Yeah.
All right.
OK.
The next thing that I'll show you is
contacts. So just like in Pipe Drive, I think I'd said this to you.
before, contacts that sort of like the...
the place where everything starts.
as far as you're marketing and outreach.
reach goes. So.
This is what you'll see. You'll get that.
email that says, "Hey, Timmy Cemento wants me."
to join Jubing and you would click the link that we
take you into Kajabi. You would log in if you're not.
already logged in and it would bring you to this page.
It would automatically just show you the piece.
people who have requested to get into the
You don't have to filter, you don't have to look for them.
it will automatically bring you in pair.
And so what I'm going to do...
I'll show you what that looks like by filtering it now.
Like I said, this--
what happened automatically just by you clicking the link.
So this is what you would see when you get that notification.
to approve people.
So you would see my name in here.
and you would have to edit.
the contact
Let me... let me... let me double check this.
I think it's actually...
There's so many...
buttons here that are like really similar to one enough.
I want to make sure I'm not steering you wrong, but.
Okay, yeah, so it's...
Go to...
So my graphics card is not great.
So it's taking a long time to bring stuff in.
Okay.
So you would just click my name.
And then...
Under.
tags see where it says pending review.
you. That is the signified. This is the
the tag that gets added to me to anybody.
who tries to sign in and this is what prevents them from
getting in because the tags are connected to automatically.
that are built in to Kajabi.
So like if somebody has a pending review tag.
They're not allowed to get into.
the community page. So it's
as simple as you going to manage tags.
It's like this.
Sorry, forgive me, Jess. No.
I mean...
Yeah, so you bring up the contact.
Because there's like a there's a tag button and then there's
manage tags. Okay, so you just click the add tag button.
And you would just do a...
approved member and hit save.
That's if you wanted to let me in.
If you know...
So for a fact you don't want them to come in, you would hit decline.
and then that would create its own
automated process to...
revoke the request of access to Jubilee.
And it would kind of just like.
set it to the side.
But the individual would not.
be able to get in after that.
Okay.
So if you change it to approved member,
The automation will.
It will automatically send.
And the approval letter, like, like...
Welcome to JUBLING. Just changing it to approve.
member will trigger that initial
sequence of like welcome to True Play.
Okay, yeah.
So once they're approved, we had approved them.
and triggers the welcome letter to go out.
- Yeah.
Amazing.
And without getting too into the weeds...
around it. This is sort of the
the secret sauce that makes
could job you a very useful thing for your--
for you guys and it's just a matter of
experimenting and honestly asking.
Chat GPT, like I want to do this.
Like I'm just trying to think of how to empower you going forward in case.
A lot of it is in automations.
Yeah.
a lot of it is in automations.
And if you like just know.
like hey in kajabi I want to accomplish
this thing automatically, like you can ask AI.
And it will tell you like what things that you can set
up what tags you can create, what automations you can create.
in order to make those things happen.
So it's...
It doesn't have to be this like arcane thing where all of a sudden you have to be
web developer like there's ways for you to be able to
to kind of pick your way through it in case it's not on the table for jubilee.
to continue to work with me.
So yeah.
So tag is added, you just see it right here.
Tag is added.
To prove member, subscribe to an email sequence.
Tag is added to proof now.
Remember, grant and offer a community access.
So like all the
the mechanical things that need to happen for people.
to get access to the site. They just happen on
automatically as a result of this tag doing what it is.
it's doing.
And it just makes it so that
As the people who are...
Okay, nice to say.
Well, I would already have it on like, you know, the book clubs.
coming up, March Book Club is coming up.
Right, and I also--
have all of the book clubs already pre scheduled in
there so like an automation would be to send
reminder to
Everyone.
to register for book club if they want or whatever.
Now, if I would do that though, I would have to.
preconceived like.
8 different emails for each other.
those or does it AI like automatically like just
reuse that information for.
Meaning like, okay, so say.
- Right, March book club is coming up.
- Okay.
And I want to send a reminder, hey, in two days.
March book clubs coming up please make sure you register.
So again, I automate that.
But now I have to do it for April, May, June, July.
because it's one time a month.
Do I have to make?
like the automation like separate.
emails for each.
No, I don't believe so.
I believe that.
You would be able to set up it's it's all about
just front loading the work rather than having to do it over and over.
You'd have to create an automation that is connected to your
to when the book club event is created.
Or just like when a book club of
that is created, then it would.
start the campaign of like T minus x days.
before, they would send out a reminder to anybody who's
registered.
to it. Basically just if you just think
out loud and think through what you
would want people to see what we
what you would want them to hear about from you.
There, yes, there would be a way to kind of
build in all that automation and a lot of that.
that a lot of what makes that possible.
is that it's not about you like hard typing in like the.
details of the book club event. It's it's using
variables. And so it's going to be
the one email campaign that you see.
that up to like remind people about it isn't
going to just refer to a specific event,
you would put in
like a variable that you can select.
that will automatically refer to the corrective value.
So that
It's, it's, again, this is another similar thing.
to pipe drive. If you set up template emails and
high drive you have like variables of like high X name,
blah, blah, blah.
Yeah, like that's the kind of thing that we would be doing.
here. So there's actually a decent amount of transference between this.
in your CRM. Okay.
Got him.
So that would just be something then like.
kind of part of next steps is like we go through this what
What automations do we want knowing the?
what's coming up the rest of the year.
And then is that kind of like a phase two then?
Like that would be...
We work with you then on phase two.
which would be okay great now we're
Now we're getting into the detail of all this.
You helped us put--
together this, that was your...
Sadhaka, now it's like okay.
The billing comes, but.
as long as we know what we want, right?
- Yeah.
it easy, give me the content then it's
you're okay going in and setting it up for us.
Yeah, and even if you want me to take an initial pass...
at putting the copy together.
If you have like a no-show idea--
of what you would want to have written on the page.
then I can draft all that.
I mean, it's like when we work on proposals.
Like you don't have to tell me like Timmy you need to say exactly
stuff. You can just tell me what you want to
convey, I will figure out how to...
do that through the copy on the page, but also the flow of the
page in the structure of the page to accomplish.
accomplish what you're looking for.
And then we just--
kind of iterate on, you know, like, do you like it?
Do you want to make it--
or if there are minor changes that you're making.
want to make that you're totally comfortable just going in and changing a half.
happy to work loud, then you don't need me to come in and do that.
for you.
OK, great.
But probably the next--
next step then is after, you know, we go through all this is just
Now we take a big picture overview of
it. What images do we want changed? What kind of
What do we need change?
What do we need moved?
And then that will finalize where we're at.
Now and then phase two, which
to be quoted where it's like, okay,
Here's to all the automations I need created.
This is
is where, who I want it to get to.
This is what I wanted to do.
to look like.
automating these letters like here's information.
I wanted to pull in. So like say, every
once a month I went a newsletter to go out by one instead.
all the events that's going on if we want to
member spotlight.
There may be content that we have to provide it, I guess.
but maybe it could remind us like.
you need to create your new software. Yeah I mean...
in theory.
Anything that you would create within Kajabi.
If it's going to be sent out through...
the architecture of Kajabi and just hang with me.
with me for a second, I'm trying to figure out
how to put this.
Like, if it's just like a one-off thing.
Then you could post that on the community page
or you can just send an email to people who
are members here and that's easy.
enough to just trigger using the email camera.
campaign here. You've done that before. I saw that.
but it goes to all the contacts.
- Yes, so if you have a--
enough thing that you want to communicate then totally you can do that.
But if there is anything that is just going to be like...
part of the offering of jubling, then
And we've worked it into the
The functionality of Kajabi, as opposed to...
to we're going to just make one thing and then the next.
next time there's an event that next time there's a newsletter we're
have to make it again. Like it is very
easy to create a situation where like the only
thing that changes is just copy or copy.
content, like an image here and there, or you.
You put in the information that you would want to send out.
out to people, but otherwise all of the...
Getting it reached out to me.
to the right people, getting it sent out.
to add the right cadence at the right time.
All of that, like, weekend wire and up front.
so that it really just is a matter of like,
okay, March newsletter.
all I have to do is write the March news letter.
matter, and that it just takes it from there.
Okay.
Yeah.
But yeah.
And there's also a template.
[ Silence ]
uploading, even though I have to write them.
It's basically I can pull it together easily.
because there's a template on building in the events.
Maybe add one or two different things that.
might relate to this month.
Exactly.
Yeah.
And
And all of that is, all of that setup.
that you would want to have, like that is something that I
I could help to build for you guys in Kajabi.
And then it's just a matter of you getting into making those.
changes.
You can.
Perfect.
but they're like the newsletter.
Here is here the all of the other functions.
that we have on the side here.
Like if you
wanted to set up, like I know that.
That's why Marcy does coaching, and I'm sure that you would be able to
to do coaching as well. Like you can kind of segment out.
all of these different offerings so that it's not
not just a bug.
just a dog piled into the community section.
It can be
be very clear. If you want this kind of
thing you go here if you want to
access like the the courses that you put together like it is
segmented out of kajabi. It's just a matter of...
setting it up so that it's not just like.
making events every time. It's easier to come.
kind of like separated out into different products.
Right, okay, so there's coaching, there's courses.
and then there's, but they don't see this part.
They would only see what were.
What were all the...
offering them, right?
They don't go.
Exactly.
Exactly. If you build it, they will copy.
If you build it, they, and you--
have it as so let me just quickly show show.
you what they would see instead.
So from the user side.
Like right now the only product that exists.
This is just the community access.
And that's where the meetups are.
That's where--
of heads are. But if you had a
podcast if you had courses like it would all be kind
of like bing bing bing bing here's the corsus section here.
the other section. You would just be able to see that.
and like this is what's available to you as a result.
result of being a member of Jubilee.
Do I want to go to the community section or do I want to go
to the course of section.
Yeah, I wonder too. I wonder too.
you think we should do like because
Because they have different membership offerings like you have.
have a...
Okay, because it says my products.
Yeah, I just.
hate the word product.
- And it doesn't have to say it.
that it's just, it's the default.
Yeah, yeah.
Because you could have
like because even accessing the community sounds
It's just like, what does that even mean?
It's like--
Sure.
jubling, you know, like maybe we can dump it downwards like.
or simplify it, I guess, is like jubling events.
Hubling.
Yes, and.
So that kind of brings me to...
The way that Kajabi is set up...
We're kind of like doing a workaround.
right now because in order to gate off.
access to information regarding.
the events like in having it not be public.
I have it kind of nestled within the
community section because that's how it was set up previously.
However, aside from this product's level,
listing here, there is an event section that you
You can create where you can use all of the image.
infrastructure that jublin gives you to make the
events available to people without it.
having to be buried in the community section.
We might even be able to get to this to the point.
point where like community is irrelevant like we don't have
to have a community section. We just need to figure out.
how to get access so that not every
everybody can just come in and see this stuff.
Okay, yeah, because I'm just like, because it's like
I don't want it to be confusing. It's like, okay, here's the story.
organization here's what they offer but now we're going
into this like community and like.
always have to log into this community.
Like I don't like.
And like being a member.
I guess
The reason we want them to be a member or sign up is so we can market.
to them and get them the stuff.
Ahh.
And the membership stuff.
is there to make it so that all the anti-seniacs.
someites that are going to cut out of the woodwork
in the next figure.
- Right, right.
- You can't just come in and start.
- Yeah, so.
We definitely need that.
I'm just wondering if like once they just--
join as a member, do they need to access the
community or you're saying that they should do that because it just
shows that they're on a different level.
or could they just go in and say okay now now.
you're here. Here's the events that you can register for. Right.
That's what I would need to
figure out within Kajabi is because you have
this extra layer of...
needing to protect your members. It does.
because Kajabi is...
in so many ways just like advertising like you're just trying.
to get people to want to join things.
you necessarily have to obscure a lot of these.
information that would be used to advertise it.
So I'll have to expect...
experiment with like what that looks like and.
what the access looks like.
The reason that it's
in community is because that's the fastest way to
get that protection right now so that people can be using it.
but I do see on the roadmap
the ability to move away from this and to
to put it so that it's more elegantly put together.
Okay.
But at the moment right now as far as
as the phase one work is.
Yeah, reworking the cop, like basically every
thing that is in place currently. I want this to
You look, feel, sound the way that you want it.
to be. I don't want us to be talking about products in here.
Whatever it is that's related to the stuff that currently is
in place like I will I will fix it for you and I will.
So right now, the next step is for Marcie.
and I to go through and like with a fine-tune
you've come and say, "Okay, love the buttons up there, but I--"
this or that. Can we change the mic?
product, take it out or just put
jubling membership, whatever it is.
And here's the image we want here.
Here's the coloring.
whatever that is.
So it's just more like what?
What is in place and what needs to be revised?
Yeah, exactly. Any pages that you have.
that you can go to currently should be fully functional.
but they may not look and feel the way that you want them to.
Like if you don't want her here, like we can change that too.
So just any of that's
stuff is still completely like on the table part of
What was the word that you used before?
like a donation or gift or whatever.
whatever. Um part of the matter.
- Sitaka?
- Oh, Sitaka, yeah, yeah.
- Sitaka.
Okay. Yeah, that's all still part of it.
Yes.
Okay.
Perfect.
I love it. I thank you so much. So let me go.
Let me get with Marcy and hopefully
by I would say.
Before the end of this week, we can get back with that and get back.
that tied up. In the meantime though, if you
You can put together then a proposal on
what it would look like then for automations.
like well maybe I need to provide you an outline of what I would want.
like what we're trying to like doing it but based
- Basically, the next step I would want is like,
okay, let's get all.
the automation setup. So if I put
Hang on, let me just say something.
Um.
If I put...
in.
I would have had another meeting.
I just don't know, I'll be late.
So if I upload all the events for the year.
than all the automations and reminders.
and signups for those events, right?
like, hey, this is coming up.
This is what it's about can be automated.
send out. Yes.
And then obviously, reminder to get.
a newsletter together and then if we want to have a
anything about after the event like a quick survey feed.
back sent out to people rating it.
was helpful and we can do that as well.
Yeah, the one that I would think about it is just like how
How this is probably over explaining.
it but then I'll let you go because I know you're gonna go.
It's just like what currently exists and like how can we like
throughout the next branches from it.
because it'll start.
to the scope, I think we'll start to expand.
a little bit more than what you guys
would want if it's like, all right, now we're going to set up
A new thing over here, we're gonna set the new thing over here.
I think just kind of it.
rating on what currently exists is the best way.
to like keep the this workable and constrain.
and so that it's not overwhelming for you to get familiar.
familiar with so many different things at once.
cool. Alright awesome yeah so when you get
chance send us over so I can send the rest of the mercy.
And then again, I'll follow up hopefully by the end.
the week to just say what changes we need and
then get an outliner if you want to put together a quote
for the next--
phase and then I think we just keep swimming.
I'm in a way if you have the time,
like to just get it done.
So.
Sure. Yeah. No, I love to. It's been fun.
Well, thanks to me. I'm sure I'll talk to you later this week.
So yeah, no problem. All right. Bye. All right.
Bye.